[Music]
oh my god you guys
we have no idea what the problem is yeah
starting to get really annoyed again
starting to get annoyed yeah the drunker
i get the more annoyed i get it happens
at technology it happens just do what i
want
why is that so hard god
[ __ ] it [ __ ] it [ __ ] it
all right do the show jenny all right
thank you so we were talking about
archetypes were we not yes we were so we
were talking about [ __ ] like
the mother archetype obviously which is
self-explanatory you got [ __ ] like the
hero archetype which
like i said it's like luke skywalker
that kind of [ __ ] you know
um also you have stuff like
i love this one mana now
this is kind of like you know how a lot
of cultures
have um a bunch of dicks
there's a bunch of dicks in their art oh
[ __ ] no i don't know well no i mean
you know how a lot of you know quote
unquote primitive cultures it's like
part of their art was
phalluses and stuff right yeah yeah well
one of the things is that even though
i feel like nowadays people like teehee
dicks that
you know what i mean that just means
sticks but the thing about it is that
dicks don't necessarily mean
physical dicks a lot of times they mean
mana or like psychic
power you know what i mean like it's
almost kind of like
it's a psychic it's a seeding kind of
thing
yeah it doesn't necessarily mean like a
physical dick
but the dick is like a manifestation of
the power of ideas or the power of
you're like seeding
something yeah it's the rocking up power
we're rocking up on you know what i mean
yeah you know what i mean so that's kind
of another archetype so
he was um because young did actually
travel
all around the world uh he went to
africa he went to india he went to
all these other places like studying all
of their mythologies and stuff like that
and for you brothers don't [ __ ] start
laughing
[Laughter]
because africa is [ __ ] filled with
dicks i saw a [ __ ]
dick weapon that came from africa it was
a bunch of [ __ ] dicks
in a kind of swastika shape on a handle
it was like a bunch of dick-shaped
knives
that you could throw at somebody and it
was a
it was a uh a traditional
african weapon yeah and it's like well
you know
these black dudes are gonna have weapons
like dicks and dicks like weapons well i
kind of feel like dudes in general yeah
all their weapons going to come at you
with the [ __ ] sharp dick but what i'm
saying is that
i don't know this is kind of hard to say
because yeah the weapons look like dicks
because they look like dicks because
dudes are like oh my dicks are the most
awesome thing my dick is the most
awesome thing ever
because you know how dudes are but
you know what i mean they're very
dick-centric
but i'm just saying that it's like it's
yes it's that
but there's like a larger um
symbolism to it in the sense that it's
not necessarily just the physical dick
but it's like it's it's a sense of
power of like seeding of psychic power
of seeding things you know sex in there
i'm all about this kind of this
discussion
[Laughter]
you knew we were going to talk about
dick sooner or later i mean i feel like
every single show it doesn't matter what
the topic is we always end up talking
about dicks yeah
why don't we never talk about vaginas
that didn't come
up i guess it doesn't come up nobody can
well and i guess apparently the
psychology of the
19th century even the psychology of
today nobody cares about china's
the psychology of amazing hunters is
phallic yeah they're very dude that's
what they were doing as i said that some
dudes are very like dick-centric
you start talking about vaginas and like
you know they don't want to talk
like you know ew gross like periods are
we going to talk about periods now oh my
god
everything's too squishy yeah it's like
oh i don't like it
yeah shit's too squishy dudes are so
sensitive
[Laughter]
they don't want to talk about periods
which it which like i said that's why it
makes me laugh to like
this was a long time ago we're talking
about dudes a long time ago
talking about this [ __ ] all right okay
but can i tell you
that just less than a year ago
yeah i saw a thread that was started by
some idiot
on twitter facebook i don't know
somewhere
some social media and apparently
i i hoped this guy was joking but i
don't think he was
that he didn't realize that women
could not hold in their periods like
they held in pay
you were telling me about that that's
right well because i read it and i was
like
they gotta hold it you gotta be kidding
right i was like why should we
why should you like not we shouldn't pay
for your [ __ ] pads or tampons
just hold it in and i was just kind of
like
do you understand how biology works
please
tell me that you were joking but the
thing about it is that
i couldn't tell if he was joking maybe
he was just really stupid
i mean just because it was on the
internet it doesn't mean it was wrong no
no but
that might have been a woman's but the
thing that it's upsetting is that you
can't tell
you can't tell if that person is
trolling or if they're just really
really trolled
that was my first instinct and that was
my mom
that was my hope yeah but on the other
hand
i have known dudes that dumb so
yeah but no i'm not going as i'm about
as dumb i'm about as dumb as a guy
no you're not dumb believe me you
really aren't [ __ ] you're really not as
dumb
as some dudes i've met all right so
that sounds like some [ __ ] dude
playing games see that's what i thought
too
but then he just kept doubling down and
doubling down and then i was just kind
of like
just because it's on the internet
doesn't mean it's real well obviously
duh
but on the other hand
i've been burned before about like i
thought this person wasn't stupid but
then they were stupid
so it's kind of like the depths of
stupid
are i don't know where the bottom is you
know what i'm saying so it's like that's
what that's why poe's law
exists because you're not really sure
it's all fun
and games because you're not really sure
if that person's like serious it's like
seriously are you serious do you need a
biology lesson do you need
like a girl to come over and tell you
that you're getting upset i'm not upset
you're getting upset over some
[ __ ] that was making [ __ ] up
that's not real i hope that he was
making [ __ ] up because if somebody
really thought that
then that would be really sad he was
trolling although like i said
he could live in like some [ __ ]
backwards place in the u.s that doesn't
have sex education that was on the
internet that probably
that may have been a 10 year old boy i
hope you don't know
i don't know that might have been a 10
year old boy
louie said i was that dumb when i was
14. yeah
that's what i thought i thought it was
like a kid yeah i said this is either an
adult
being an [ __ ] and just pretending or
this is a child
we got connor botswana on [ __ ] what's
up khan
and then see this is what i thought see
dan says the bottom of stupidity is an
endless chasm see that's what i thought
too
because i kind of feel like i'm okay
like i'm cautiously optimistic
i said come on
how are you doing tom i've never seen
you so [ __ ] up i think it's what he's
saying
i find that hard to believe you've been
way more [ __ ] up than that
[Music]
i mean i feel like i'm still pretty
coherent i'm gonna go to i'm gonna come
down to mexico
you wait and see is that a threat yeah
it's a threat man i was watching i was
watching a [ __ ] program
of uh of mexico and they were it was
it was it was um i think it was a vice
program
and they were showing all the [ __ ] uh
[ __ ] that was happening
out in the middle of nowhere out in
mexico with the
with the cartels and everything those
[ __ ] are little
they're little bitty dudes little bitty
little bitty dudes and it's like i am
also a little bitty dude
so i'm not hating you guys don't
understand something man
[ __ ] khan khan of ozan that dude's
nearly six foot something that's a huge
mexican that's a [ __ ]
an ubermensch level mexican he's big man
he's a big he's a big mexican guy
i'm gonna go down there and [ __ ] yeah
he's a big old mexican guy he's going to
protect me
when i go to mexico you can protect me
he's going to protect him he's going to
protect me
little tom yeah we're going to go down
there and we'll [ __ ]
go down there to tijuana i'm small too
yeah he's going to protect me
i'm smaller
[Laughter]
yeah he was showing me what i could get
for [ __ ] eighteen hundred dollars a
month in mexico
it's twice as much as this house twice
as big
he's trying to talk me into moving to
mexico we're gonna go to mexico
for a [ __ ] i'll consider it my
spanish is shitty though
you learn it i took well i know i took
it for four years but
it's i'm for what we're paying here we
can get a palace in mexico
on the beach if you like some [ __ ] out
of a james bond movie
gotta put all my stuff in [ __ ]
storage though
why is that can't take all these [ __ ]
motorcycles and all these guns and stuff
down in mexico they can't have all that
well just put it in [ __ ] storage
maybe later
[Laughter]
food's good there you know it's gonna be
good i would
get fat eating tacos down there dude i
saw that taco show
yeah it's just looking good looking yeah
i mean i'm
i was super into mexican food before
that and then we watched that
taco show and i was just kind of like
i'm
i might eat all that i mean all that i
said it's a good thing i don't live down
there because i would eat
all that every single day yeah
because america's over bro
oh it's fine it's just over it's fine
okay
it'll be all right yeah
dan says i'm only little at five nine
yeah bro
i'm five three kahn says that you get a
cenote
and a beach included with all that [ __ ]
oh it's an old day
yeah wait i've seen some horror movies
about cenotes
i mean you know i'm not a verse like i
said
my spanish is terrible yeah
i took it for four years yeah took
french for three years
do you think i remember any of that [ __ ]
i do not
but you know so what was i talking about
dicks
[Laughter]
well you know i had to get an edition
yeah manna
well like i said you do kind of see
this whole thing about
and if you look into like anthropology
and
all that kind of stuff you do see a lot
of like dick centered art
and while i do feel that a lot of it is
just like hey
look at my dick i do feel like there's
an element of that going on because i
know what dudes are like
and they think their dudes are like
their dicks are like the end all be all
but there is kind of like a symbology
involved where
it's kind of like i'm i'm seeding
the the nation you know what i mean
so i i kind of feel like there's that
symbology going on
man it's much earlier than mankind just
goes all the way back to bob
to ball and bay sure that's what i'm
saying these are rain gods
and [ __ ] fertility gods zac says
there's a penis museum in iceland
well that's where you need to be zack
thank you victor thanks vic wait there's
a penis museum
okay yeah i might have there's something
to go check that out
there's a penis museum in japan
well there's a sex museum in new york
which i have been to yeah
not necessarily penises why is there a
new vagina museum
they got that too is there a vagina
museum anybody know
dicks and grits that's what victor says
oh my god that should be our that should
be our channel
let me go check on the cat yeah we're
spooky dicks and grits
is there a vagina museum anywhere
now i'm curious i'm sure there's like
dick museums everywhere
but you know and i've been to the sex
museum in new york so
like i said um so yeah i was talking
about mana
as i said not necessarily dick centric
but
spiritual power you know because it's
like yeah
i'm spraying the world with my seed
with my spiritual power like a fire hose
you know mana um also
another thing that young came up with
was an archetype called
the shadow now i guess
roughly this is sort of equivalent to
freud's
uh you know um idea of the id
this is basically this is your dude
that is like part of your subconscious
that is like the dark side of your ego
this is like your
the evil that you're capable of
um the animalistic side of you that's
like sociopathic
so that's kind of uh that whole thing
there um and when you look into
the symbology of
mythologies around the world you see
this kind of thing where um
one symbol that recurs is the snake
obviously
very uh prevalent in judeo-christian
mythology um but also like
demons dragons that kind of stuff um
this
kind of symbol like this creature
is always cardi you know guarding
like a pool of water or a cave or
something like that
and the cave or the water
is kind of seen as a symbol of the
unconscious mind so this is like so it's
almost kind of like
he saw this symbology as
this evil side the shadow is guarding
your unconscious like you can't get to
it you know what i mean
it's kind of like that so that was
another thing now i want to talk to
about the persona this was another kind
of big
thing that he talked about a lot now the
persona
is essentially your
public face i guess you would want to
call it
this is the face that you show to
other people in your public life but
that is not necessarily
you so
i feel like young
i don't know i and this might be
something that was
um you know put upon him like from
modern times but i feel like he
thought that people were too
worried about their persona as in
their public face this was the face that
you showed to
the public that was not necessarily you
this is like your fake
person that you put on it sounds like a
japanese concept
well that no it was true at the time
this was yeah this was something that it
came up with well this was like
this is the person fake yeah it's like
you know you go to work and this this
this is the you know personality that
you put forth this is not really you
though
this is your public face that was that's
mostly from another time
in in the western world it's not it's
not that
it's not like that like it was anymore
which is good because seriously i've
never been comfortable
yeah i think i think i think people
changed a lot this is
this is this is [ __ ] late 1800s stuff
i mean dude this is just me i'm not yeah
you know i'm not any different
on this [ __ ] it's only like that than i
am in real life it's only like that like
in japan and china
today
yeah i'm just saying like back in the
day that was like kind of a big thing
because
you went out in the world with your fake
face
with your fake face and that was kind of
like what you put across everybody but
that wasn't what you were really like
right um yeah like you said it's
probably less relevant nowadays because
now i kind of feel like we
we know so much about people nowadays
it's just kind of like bro keep that to
yourself
yeah right you know we can see through
all that nowadays
well and the thing about it is like look
we have shows like this like our show
which is just us being
our drunk ass selves right
i don't even know how to be another
person yeah
i have a hard enough time being this
person
they didn't have honesty back then much
less being
like expending my energy being some
other person
you know they didn't have honesty back
then in europe
not in the way we had well there was a i
mean i feel like back in the day
and maybe in some cultures nowadays back
in the day there was a much
um you know it was a much like
a bigger distinction between your public
face
and your private face yeah like only so
many people
saw your [ __ ] home body life you know
what i mean it's like you and your wife
and your kids
not a lot of people saw that [ __ ] what
you really believed and what you were
really like
yeah nobody saw that so it's like you
had to like you know you when you went
out in the
day you kind of put on that persona
well it was with all the [ __ ] suit
and all the kind of [ __ ] it was like
that
it was like that in mississippi when i
was a kid
there was [ __ ] the kind of like
social
front people put on you know i remember
growing up remember that yeah yeah yeah
that's what they're talking about
i mean i feel like that's a lot less
relevant now yeah it's not relevant
um particularly like i said in the
you know social media kind of [ __ ]
because well
i don't know i don't i don't know if
it's more or less relevant because you
do have the thing where
particularly people that have a large
social media presence
say like instagram influencers if you
want to go that far
um people it's like you know that that's
not their real life the [ __ ] that
they're portraying on social media
yeah that that is curated and they want
you to
see them at a particular light so
they are particularly putting up
these particular pictures these
particular videos
and you know bad [ __ ] that happens
they're not showing that
yeah well i remember i remember people
when i was a kid in mississippi that
were
that were curated like that they
wouldn't say certain things they didn't
cut sure
they [ __ ] constantly had us like i
said i think people like feel like that
shit's so
out if you were to see that today it
would
it would come across as being so fake
and out of style now you know what i
mean yeah but back in those days that
was just the way a lot of people were
i'm glad that that's gone although you
know like i said i think that people
here's the thing rock got rid of that
yeah
i think people [ __ ] on social media um
these days for that reason because they
feel like well you're only
you're curating people's experience of
you
um you're only posting what you want
people to see and [ __ ] like that
but the thing about it is that people
have always done that
it's just that now you can do it to a
larger audience
you know what i'm saying so i don't
really see that much difference
because i feel like back in the old days
people were still doing that
all of your bad [ __ ] was happening
privately
in your house and [ __ ] you didn't want
getting out
you were kind of like yeah let's
suppress that [ __ ] let's
project this particular thing out into
the community
um it's just that it was on a lot more
local level
back then yeah okay so it does still
happen nowadays but i do kind of feel
like
it's not that different than it used to
be back then you know what i'm saying
i i just think it's a bigger scale yeah
because but people are more aware of it
now
i remember i remember my grandmother
on my dad's side in mississippi
worried about little things you know
what i mean and putting on a [ __ ]
front for an audience of one or two
back in mississippi yeah that's the way
it was back then well and the thing
about it
like people in my grandmother's
generation they were very worried about
[ __ ] to happen within their family yeah
and
[ __ ] should that happen within their
little tiny local community yeah and how
it would be
perceived by people who knew them right
it's ridiculous you know we can't talk
about this because this side of the
family would get upset about it we can't
yeah it's weird to look at it now
because those people are all dead
well and nowadays you're all dying your
audience is a lot more global
if you want to say that so i'm not
saying that people don't still do it
nowadays because obviously they do
um you know particularly people who are
you know posting to social media so you
know you obviously want to
put your best face across you don't want
um yeah it was very different back then
though
right that's what i mean but it's like
it's like people [ __ ] about it nowadays
but i feel like
one it's not that different and two
in a lot of ways i i i don't know i kind
of feel like it's better
i mean back yeah now because back in the
old days all kinds of horrible [ __ ]
was happening and nobody
wanted to talk about it nobody a lot of
times they didn't think it was horrible
exactly well that's why that's why they
thought that was the normal way of doing
things
well like i said look at something like
or that it was right
yeah like look at something like you
know domestic abuse spousal abuse
that was something that to a large
extent was
normalized i'm not saying that people
thought it was good
but it was normalized in the sense that
oh well that's just something that
happened
and i could see this in my grandparents
generation
also my parents generation this was
something that
it just happened no one thought of
reporting it
to authorities because that was just
something that you did
your wife said something [ __ ] up you
smacked her around
and i was keeping a [ __ ] in line that
exactly and that was just something that
you did everybody did it
yeah and it was just kind of and like i
said i'm not saying that's good
i'm saying that's bad it was another
time but back then
nobody thought of it as bad enough to
merit reporting
it was it was another time yeah it was
different kind of people back then
it doesn't really equate to to today
i kind of remember some of it but
it also wasn't there wasn't that much of
it
maybe there was but i i wasn't i don't
know i kind of feel like there's a long
time ago
the thing about it is that there's
really no way of knowing how much of it
there was because
it was it was coming back well it was
disencouraged it wasn't encouraged to
report it like because why would you
report it
people were dumb back then too they're
you're not talking about the same people
and i remember as movies were starting
to come out of the 80s
that kind of [ __ ] was kind of mentioned
and it was kind of [ __ ]
laughed at that that [ __ ] had happened
it was out of style though well it
wasn't really considered like i said it
wasn't
really considered that serious no it
wasn't that serious
it wasn't that serious but it was also i
remember being
i remember that it was considered to be
something from another era
i mean because i remember seeing movies
back then
where a dude would like a woman would
like mouth off to a woman
or to a man right and like the dude
would like smacker and like it was
like played for laughs yeah
and that was just kind of the way that
everyone
saw it nobody thought this is something
this is abuse or
nobody thought that we should report it
it's like everybody thought oh it's just
kind of funny yeah that [ __ ] mouth
here's the thing though i saw that in
movies but i didn't see that in real
life
so i don't know how common it actually
was but that's the thing you don't know
because it was normalized by the culture
and
you don't so you don't know because
the thing about it is that culture you
know
what happens in movies what happens in
the culture at large
that does have an effect on how people's
lives are lived so you don't know
if some [ __ ] was going on
because you know not to say but like my
grand
mother and my grandfather i don't know
if there was like abuse going on but
that's the thing i don't know
because it was like normalized so
if that [ __ ] was going on with them
they wouldn't have said anything about
it i don't think it was
i mean they wouldn't have said anything
about it because it was just like not
something that you talked about
so i'm sure it was probably more
widespread
than people believed because
you know at the time it was kind of like
not considered a big deal
well do you want it to be widespread or
do you not want it to be widespread
no i don't want it to be widespread i
just i don't think it was i just think
that it probably was a lot more
widespread than people thought because
it's sad no it's sad because because
i just i just feel like people thought
it was okay
so nobody reported or they thought oh
well it must been
not that big a deal because nobody else
was making a big deal about it
so i don't know like i think there's a
lot of cultural aspects about that that
it kind of i think it was just comedy i
don't think that was widespread
i see i disagree with you on that i
think it was probably uh
widespread it's just that i mean the
thing about it is that
you know since you have to say like
since time immemorial
um [ __ ] like this like [ __ ] like
dudes like beating up on women for like
not doing whatever
i kind of feel like that's been
mostly normalized so you have to think
that
you get to a point where it's like well
no one's gonna complain about it because
what the [ __ ] no one's gonna do anything
about it so you're not gonna complain
so i it gets to a point where it just
keeps happening
and no one says anything about it
because why would you it's like
nothing's gonna get done
so it's like what's the point of it so
i mean from my point of view i think it
was probably a lot more widespread than
than is probably reported because i kind
of feel like a lot of people didn't
report it
for the very reason that no one would
have taken
particularly seriously back in that day
because it just wasn't taken seriously
like i said you see movies from [ __ ]
the 60s even the 70s
and dudes are like smacking women around
and like [ __ ] and
it's played for laughs or people
actually yeah whatever and the women are
like yeah whatever i deserve that or
whatever so it's just kind of like
in a way you know movies are a
reflection of culture culture or
reflection of movies it's kind of like a
you know it's a feedback loop so i do
kind of feel like
there was probably a lot more of that
going on than we like to admit
um but it just
no one said anything about it because
they didn't really see the point
of reporting it because nothing would
have been done
and they would have gotten in trouble so
i you know that that's what that's where
i'm coming from i'm just saying that
i don't know i i just feel like that's
probably the case
i don't know but i feel like that's
probably the case
so what was that talking about okay so i
talked about
the persona like i said and we were
talking about that a little bit earlier
where
this is kind of like the mask that you
portray to the rest of the world as i
said
probably less relevant to
today's world but i don't know i
i don't know because i do kind of feel
like people
you know they have their social media
thing and that's that's like a whole
branding that's a whole thing that they
portray
i don't do that because i get [ __ ] up
on the show and
like i said this is what i show on this
show this is just me i'm not being
any different than what i would normally
be like but
i can see how that would still be
relevant but that was kind of like a big
thing that
that was like the social thing that you
portrayed and i mentioned this earlier
but
another thing that he uh that young came
up with is animide animus
now he was a little bit i gotta say he
got to be a little bit ahead of his time
in this anime and animus now he
theorized that every single person
had both male and female aspects he was
going back to the [ __ ]
greeks on this perhaps earlier um
because the greeks had the whole thing
it's like oh you know it's
humans they have the female the male
half it's like they get separated
they're always trying to look for their
other half so that's kind of like
where he was coming from with that so
he had a thing where every man
had something in him called the anima
which was the female aspect
every woman had something of the male
aspect and was called the animus
and the fact that these
uh aspects of their personality were
being denied
were making humans being
unable to reach their entire full
potential because they weren't embracing
both sides of their personality so like
i said
young was a little bit ahead of his time
with this whole anime animus thing where
everybody had both aspects male
female in their personalities to greater
or lesser degrees
and the fact that they couldn't um
access those or they couldn't express
those freely
um were you know getting in the way of
them being
individuated or being like
self-actualized as you would call it
later on
um so you had that whole thing and then
you know there were some other
archetypes she had like i said
you had the child you had the hero you
had all that kind of
stuff which i mentioned earlier you also
got like a trickster archetype
hermaphrodite that's another one um
but he also had something and one of his
archetypes
was called the self
and this was basically your
identity like
the thing that was continuing your
identity that made you feel like you
but as i said his young's kind of
um end game was that you needed to be
individuated which meant that all of
your
aspects of your personality all of the
archetypes everything had to be
imperfect and complete
balance so you had to find a balance
between
your conscious self your unconscious
self
the collective unconscious you had to
kind of find
a balance of all of those things
where you were kind of
content i guess so that was what he was
shooting for he wasn't really shooting
for
because i feel like he kind of got on on
freud's case
for freud being like hey you have this
neurosis you're like [ __ ] up because
of this and your mom did this and then
the other thing
and i think that young thought that was
too
limiting and young was more kind of like
look we just need to find like whatever
[ __ ] happened to you in your childhood
we just need to get over that and we
just need to find a place
we need to find your happy place kind of
thing
like wait he didn't say that but he's
like we need to find your happy place
where you're kind of like just
balanced between yourself your
unconscious self
and everyone and you just kind of have
to find this kind of zen
where you live in that area
yeah you know what i mean which like i
said i you know i can see
it sounds far-fetched to me yeah but i
see
like the appeal of it because in a way
that is kind of what you have to do
in your life at least if you want to be
happy you kind of have to find
that balance between yourself
everyone else and
all of the [ __ ] that you dealt with in
your upbringing
you have to deal with that however you
deal with it
you have to come to an understanding of
what you're like how you react with the
world
what the world is like you have to kind
of come to that place where you're just
kind of like
this is where i'm at i'm occupying this
space
and i'm just gonna
chill right here everything's gonna be
fine so
i get that i you know what i mean i i
kind of get that
that's kind of what he was saying in the
modern parlance you kind of got to get
to this point where
you got to find your little well no you
got to find your little little area
between
what makes you happy what makes everyone
else happy what's
you know what's your past like you got
to deal with that [ __ ] just [ __ ]
you got to be in this place right now
all right so
in that way i feel like that's why maybe
he has like a
more of an enduring legacy than freud
does
because he had a lot wider
scope i guess than freud did
in this you know what i'm saying like in
the sense that
he was very willing to deal with
people's individual
uh you know their kind of things that
they were dealing with like in
interior you know their interior [ __ ]
you got to deal with all that [ __ ] and
make that work
with the outside world i have to think
about it i'm pretty [ __ ] up right now
well just give it give a shirt come on
you can do it
give a shirt sounds it sounds a little
bit airy fairy if you ask me
it's not though it's not it's it's
really i mean and i'm like the least new
agey person ever
like i don't have a lot of patience but
i kind of have a new age kind of a feel
to it
um it does have that aspect
i will give you that right which like i
said i don't like that either
but i mean one thing
that i mean he does have like a holistic
approach to [ __ ]
i always kind of had this [ __ ] kind
of weird
i had this opinion that how do you
become okay with
what other people think
well you know what i mean i'm like i
don't really care about what other
people
think so maybe that's part of what he's
talking about yeah that well i think
that that might be
you don't have to i can't control what
other people think so how did well what
does that have to do with me
you know nothing right nothing that was
something that
whenever we whenever we're talking about
this jungian stuff
they're always talking about the uncut
you know the cosmic unconsciousness
or [ __ ] like that you know what i mean
like what
other people are thinking or what other
people
don't think and i always thought that
was kind of hokey
i don't think it's necessarily that i
think he's just taught other people
don't
you no no no it's nothing to do with
that it's not it's nothing to do with
controlling other people's thoughts or
anything like that
he's just saying that everybody if you
were a human
you're drawing from the same
well of experience that's all he's
saying so
a lot of the symbology a lot of the
things that you dream about a lot of the
things that you think about
um that has a precedent
in other people's thought processes also
he's not saying
that you should
worry about what other people are
thinking or what he's just saying that
we're all drawing from a common
yeah well right that's all he's saying
yeah and that's kind of where i disagree
i don't think what i experience has
anything to do with other people
you know i mean i think i think
existence in life
is totally subjective it has to do with
your point of view
and when you're experiencing life you're
not really thinking about the way other
people experience it
which i don't know exactly what he's
talking about that might have been
it might have been thinking that might
be a certain kind of
certain kind of thinking that only
existed in his day
i don't know you know i mean maybe i
mean what's he talking about race
memories
well he's just talking well human
memories
in the sense that everybody
from our ancestral history not even just
humans but going back to
prior to when we were humans yeah we all
have a similar
species experience in the sense that
you know he was talking about [ __ ] like
you know
a large percentage of humans for example
are scared of
snakes or spiders or the dark or
something like that and he's just saying
that that
is um a common thing that a lot of
people
like that a lot of humans have that
might be
indicative of something that happened
like way back in our ancestral memory
and that we all have that and we can all
tap into that
that's kind of all he's saying oh okay
so and he's saying that we all
because so many human uh myths so many
human like fairy tales all kind of story
stuff like that have similar
themes similar symbols like reoccurring
in them
so obviously we all share
um some kind of symbological
similarity that's all he's saying is
that we're all like drawing back on that
kind of [ __ ]
i you know to be perfectly honest i
think he's wrong
all right i think
i think people people may have
certain kind of memories and cultural
memories
uh inc in common with people of their
culture
but for instance like okay
here's here's a good example in mexico
mexico has a different
common culture you know what i mean
there are certain things that
that they're into based upon their
culture that
say like somebody of european descent
doesn't really experience
it's not exactly the same you know what
i mean
they went through it they had a totally
different
history and i i just i don't think
people are exactly the same
all people are people but i think that
they
have different identities if you if you
know what i mean
um and that's not a bad thing i mean
that that's what diversity is
is about people have their own
histories in their own cultures well i
don't think young was denying that
i just i think he was saying that we all
have a common well
it just expresses itself differently in
different cultures
depending on how you grew up because
like i said he he traveled all over the
world he went to africa he went to india
and he went all over the place but he
could see similarities
yeah between all of the mythologies of
different cultures even you know as
vastly different as the cultures were
he saw some like similarities like at
the core
between particular things so he was kind
of trying to show
that all humans have this
nugget of similarity at the bottom and
it's like we all have these same symbol
we just interpret them
in different ways depending on how our
culture is
that's all okay that's all he was saying
and like i said i don't think that's
particularly a controversial
point of view to have strong guys says
dude where's my car
because that seems like a pretty you
know
yeah i mean the thing about it is like
look at something like
i'm just trying to pull something out of
my ass here um something that's common
across all cultures dragons
so you know say something like dragons
which is a mythological
uh thing which is based a lot of people
i think
you know feel like it's based in
european mythology but you know asian
mythology has it also and like there's
there's equivalence to dragons in pretty
much every human culture that you would
care to name
so something like that is something that
he was pointing to
as all human cultures have something
equivoc
equivalent to a dragon so
there must be something in the human
memory
that is something like a dragon or that
must be a symbol of
something that all humans share because
everybody has that you know what i'm
saying that's all he was saying
okay it just manifests itself in
different ways
in different cultures depending on where
you grew up and depending
on how your culture evolved okay
that's all he was saying there he's not
saying everyone's the same he's not
saying that everyone's
he's not saying that he's just saying
that there are certain
core uh things that are very similar
across all cultures around the world
across
all times that um
that that's something that bears looking
into because
that obviously is something that is
important to humans as a whole
you know so like i said
you know one thing that he pointed out
like i said you know fear of spiders
fear of
snakes [ __ ] like that which is almost
universal across
human cultures he's like there's got to
be something
evolutionary behind that you know
yeah which like i said that's not crazy
okay i mean a lot of
scientists have said that as well
because
i mean you have to think about it like i
said you know humans
obviously we evolve from apes in one
particular place and then spread outward
so it wouldn't be i mean
it wouldn't be weird to think that we
all had very particular
you know types of uh
paths that our brains go on
um it just manifests itself differently
depending on wherever you ended up
right you know might be a little bit
different in this area
like our dragon might look a little bit
different than your dragon but it's
still a dragon
you know what i'm saying yeah that's
kind of what he was getting it
with the whole collective unconscious
thing so that's what i'm saying why
i don't think that theory is crazy
because it seems
i mean it it seems like almost
self-evident um
but you know is it scientifically
provable i don't know but there are
enough similarities between
stories across cultures across times and
[ __ ] like that that obviously
human brains which have evolved like
every other
structure um have parameters
and those parameters interact
differently with whatever
situation that they find themselves in
you know that's all
what are you doing i'm looking to see
how much is left
well that yeah i mean you know because
looks we're only halfway through it
well i can just like leave it because
you seem like you're getting kind of
cranky
i'm getting kind of cranky you're
getting fussy i'm not getting cranky
he's getting fussy yeah all right i
i read this one thing this was an
interesting thing
that i read and i just kind of wanted to
get into this before we before we
end it was that what i was laughing at
you
why are you laughing at me i'm getting
fussy
you're always you're always fussy like a
baby he's like a baby that gets fussy
and you have to like give him his
battles
and put him down and stuff it's
ridiculous
honestly the older i get the more i
treat men like babies this is ridiculous
because they they act like babies so you
have to like interact with them like
babies that's not what it is
okay if you insist
but um yeah so the thing about it
how young came up with this stuff this
was very interesting to me and like this
uh this very long like uh paper that i
found somewhere like kind of put this in
really good terms
so he was talking about
the aspect of quote unquote the shadow
which
like i said fred would call the id this
is like your dark side
and young believed that you had this
[ __ ]
but if you denied that you had this [ __ ]
then that was gonna [ __ ] you in the ass
later on
wait what i mean that's like i'm
paraphrasing but i'm just saying that
he just thought like if you denied that
you had these horrible shitty feelings
then they would just like grow and grow
and go and then like later on they would
cause you trouble
like down the line so the example that
he gave he's like so
if you're a kid and you feel like
you're real um you know you want to help
all the little animals and whatnot
so you find this little birdie that's in
the forest
and he's hurt and you pick him up
and they're like for a second you feel
like this little birdie in his little
like wing is broken or whatever and you
pick him up and he's like really really
light
and if you think to yourself for one
second man
i could totally just smush this bird
because he's so
small and helpless he's like don't
deny that you felt that because you did
feel that
if you no he's just saying if you
deny that you felt that and you like
suppress it
yeah then it will come back worse later
it sounds like he's like
dude just deal with it like you you
thought for a second
that you wanted to smush that this is
some everybody thought that
it's like just he's like it's better for
you to just
it's better for you to just acknowledge
that you felt that horrible feeling
and then you just helped the bird and it
was fine yeah but it's like if you
acknowledge that you felt that evil
feeling yeah then
that will be better for you than if you
suppress it or deny it
because later on that will come back to
him stop it this is
this is some [ __ ] l ron hovered [ __ ]
that's like some [ __ ] that [ __ ]
elrond hubbard would come up with
it would it would it is well i can see
the saying i can see what he's saying
though i can see what he's saying
because
everybody has that okay so like you know
i don't even want to feel like little
like crushed birds because that's
upsetting but this is
everybody like look if you go to the
grand canyon everybody that's like
weird yeah everybody has well that's
what he's saying
that's what he's saying he's saying like
look everybody goes to the grand canyon
for example yeah
and i just and i just jumped off
everybody like look
everybody's i was on the top of the
empire state building i thought about
jumping off everyone does
so it's kind of like he was kind of
saying
everybody has those feelings okay
own it yeah and move on
if you deny that you felt that
because it was like a shitty feeling
it's like you know don't push anyone off
don't but yeah but he's like the more
you suppress that
he's like the worse it's going to be
down the line because you'll keep
suppressing these negative feelings that
you have
no no no it's like it's true because i
feel like the more you feel like
oh i shouldn't feel like that and you
just keep tamping it down
i feel like it might kind of come back
to bite you in the ass later on
look acknowledge that everybody feels
like everybody if you go to the end of
the
edge of the grand canyon everybody is
like man i could jump off or i could
push somebody
everybody feels like that everybody so
it's like don't let me tell you what
he's doing
okay that's just that's just a normal
psychological thing you know what i mean
like
i was walking by the cat what would
happen if i went
and smashed pookie but that's just
[ __ ]
and that's just like a [ __ ] normal
thing but that's what he's saying
that's what he's saying that that is
normal right everybody feels that
because that's
the point the average person also thinks
about the [ __ ] worst possible
scenario
well that exactly that's what he that's
what he was saying that's all he's
talking about
that's what he's saying but then he's
going to come out and say if you deny
that you thought that you'll blow up
that's what he's talking about well he's
just saying that's not good
to deny that you feel that because
everybody feels like it's very exciting
to step on a crack break your mama's
back well yeah
but like i said that's what he taught
him that's the whole thing is that he
was acknowledging
that everyone that a normal person feels
like that
crap like like you said like you you
pick up a little bird and you're like oh
i can squish it it's like
almost everybody feels it and he's like
that's normal
well it's because you [ __ ] have kind
of like
whenever you're doing something there's
always an internal fear of
what would happen if exactly that's what
he's saying
that's what he's saying he's like that's
not you
that's you [ __ ] thinking of what
would happen
you know what i mean right but that was
right but that was the point that he was
making
is that everybody feels that
and that denying it if you like
if you think that you're denying it and
like
that and you feel like oh i'm a bad
person because i thought that
he's like that's not good because
everybody feels like that you didn't
think that
yeah you did though not really what it
is is what it is
that your mind [ __ ] was afraid of the
worst possible scenario
and it showed it to you yeah but that's
what he's saying it's like
every human has that it's normal
and he was just trying to put across
that that was a normal feeling to have
and that the fact that you think that
it's abnormal
and you make some kind of like complex
about it yeah
that's gonna like be bad later on all
right so he should
he was just trying to make the point
that exactly what you said
that is a normal thing for people to do
to think of the worst case scenario and
[ __ ] like that
so that was kind of what he was getting
at it's like don't get all like [ __ ]
hung up on that because
i'm actually agreeing with him maybe i
am agreeing with him
i i don't know i don't care if i'm
agreeing with him or not
i'm just saying that it's
the mind has a weird ability of saying
don't do this don't do that that's all
that's all it's doing but that's what he
was saying yeah but if you deny it
if you deny that that happened you won't
blow up
that's not exactly what he was saying he
was just saying that it's not
good to deny that because you're denying
a normal human response it's like it's a
normal human response to think oh this
is the worst thing that can happen yeah
don't do it
and he's like don't like just your mind
saying don't do this and don't right
he's like if you deny that and say oh
i'm an evil person for thinking that
then that might cause you problems later
but she didn't really
think that but you didn't really think
that you were shown
you were shown a bad outcome so you can
avoid it
that's all it is but that's what he's
saying yeah that's what he's saying it's
like don't
get hung up on like your mind showing
you this that the other thing and you
think that makes you a bad person
he's like that doesn't make you a bad
person denying
that vision makes you a bad person
because
good you're you know what i'm saying
yeah
i'm just it it it's frustrating me
because you just keep
whatever i don't care i'm trying to get
to a certain thing and you just keep
i'm gonna see if the poop says i was
gonna see it
okay well
yeah scott got it if you dwell on guilt
based on the thought you'll give
yourself a complex exactly
that's what he was saying he was like
don't get all [ __ ]
head up about oh my god i thought of
like
squishing squishing this bird that was
in my hand or i thought about stepping
on pookie or i thought about something
like that
it's like everybody thinks like that
everybody has those thoughts
it's fine but it's like you just have to
have them and you just have to kind of
realize that everyone has that
but if you start getting a complex about
it if you start getting
um you know if you start dwelling on it
if you start doing that [ __ ] then that
is going to cause you problems later on
that's all he was saying
um was that he was just
you know trying to bring people to an
understanding look everybody has a dark
side everybody has
these [ __ ] crazy ass thoughts it's
like [ __ ] comes into your head
you don't know why it's in there i've
had it happen you've had it happen
everybody's had it happen and it's like
it's [ __ ] fine
you just you just have to like not dwell
on it
because you think that you're the only
person that's
thought that that's kind of what that's
where he was coming from with that
because i think he was trying to
he was trying to establish that
everybody
has those thoughts and that
if you have a thought like that and you
think that that makes you
a psychopath or you think that something
like that or you
start to deny it because you're guilty
about it then that might lead to
problems later on
but you have to understand that
everybody has
those thoughts everybody even the best
[ __ ] people
that's all he was saying so
you know like i said everybody has that
kind of well hey sweetie
come on jump oh my goodness why don't
you come up and put your butt in the
camera
give me oh my god oh yeah it's pookie
pokey's thinking and she's like [ __ ] you
daddy
getting out of here nope i'm busy can
you come back
just come back
ken says [ __ ] happens keep on keeping on
that's exactly
exactly i think that's kind of all young
was saying about that
was that he understood that everyone had
like terrible thoughts
but you're not acting on them
and everyone has them so quit beating
yourself up about
it that's kind of that's how i
interpreted that
is you know yeah you know what i'm
saying she's biting
why are you biting because she's mad at
you
and she's not mad
so do you have anything of substance to
contribute to this discussion
are you just not i'm i'm too [ __ ] up
really yeah i'm drunk so you really
you don't have anything further to
contribute nah i'm tired of it
well thank you you're very very helpful
you're so helpful
is that it is that all you have on this
i guess i don't you know what i mean
it's late i mean we've been doing the
show about four hours now
well i don't know it stopped like yeah
it's been about four hours
i think we got it covered you got you do
we have it covered people i guess
yeah we got covered
you want to do the um the outro
no you can do it alright everybody if
you like the show go ahead and [ __ ]
like
share and subscribe we're going to try
to piece the show back together because
it's probably in two or three different
pieces
well it's in three different pieces yeah
it's [ __ ] up
well what the hell was that
who knows yeah don't don't let us like
bore you or anything
[Laughter]
all right we'll um we'll get back with
you next week
and um like i said i'm not sure
like we might do a matinee tomorrow but
i'm not sure if we will
because i'm going to ocala tomorrow
if i get back in time to do a show
we will do a show but we might not
um if we don't then i will do one an
extra one on thursday to make up for it
oh my god
what do you do she's licking her butt
yeah you guys
then she rolls oh my goodness get the
camera get the camera get the camera
get her get her yes you can get her get
her
what the [ __ ] look at her look at her
[Laughter]
what you doing folks we get a little
belly yeah oh my goodness
okay she's like why are you filming me
all right we got it seriously all right
remember
like share subscribe like what do you
[ __ ] it up
okay like share subscribe and all your
social media
be sure to oh my goodness um
well she's gonna come and say hi to
everybody you gonna step on the [ __ ]
chips
okay she's right here
oh my goodness oh my goodness
okay we'll see you guys later yeah be
sure to uh
check out all this [ __ ] on social media
if you would like to
financially support the show go to our
patreon page patreon.com
13 o'clock podcast or you can go to our
blog 13 o'clock podcast.wordpress.com
and there's a link in the sidebar to a
paypal account if you'd like to give a
one-time donation anything
is much appreciated man
cash movies whatever it's like we love
all of it
and we will be back either tomorrow or
monday
we'll see how it goes um i might be out
of town tomorrow but we'll see
and uh so that'll do it for tonight
thanks for dropping by
and we'll see you later bye